[Musique]
et bien bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle vidéo dans laquelle nous allons
parler d'un sujet qui me fait du bien en
ce moment ça se lâche un peu sur les
sujets quoi après les animaux qui est ce
que c'est qu'est ce que c'est les modes
sur les jeux vidéo
aucun rapport c'est bon oui je vous
parle de ça parce qu'il ya des modes qui
sont extrêmement drôle mais avant je
vais vous parler un petit peu de
l'histoire des modules de jeux vidéo
personnellement c'est un truc que
j'adore pour plusieurs raisons et
j'aimerais vous expliquer déjà ce que c
est vous dire pourquoi je trouve que
c'est quelque chose de génial sur
certains jeux vidéo il est possible que
les joueurs créer un mode c'est à dire
un nouveau contenu une nouvelle manière
de jouer au jeu auquel on joue et c'est
quelque chose qui a paru dans les années
80 en tout cas les premiers modes de
jeux qui sont devenus assez populaire
pour l'époque c'était dans les années 80
il y avait par exemple à l'époque un jeu
qui s'appelait castle wolfenstein dans
lequel on combattait des nazis et il ya
des joueurs qui ont créé un mode ça
remplace tous les nazis par les
schtroumpfs et ils ont appelé le mode
castle smartphone stein donc castle
schtroumpfs weinstein en france est
personnellement j'ai commencé à jouer à
des modes sur counter strike 1.6 il ya
pas mal de temps je jouais beaucoup au
mode surf pour ceux qui connaissent
c'est un module y avait des rentes et on
pouvait finalement faire du surf dessus
et volets c'était vraiment sympa y avait
aussi le mode zombie qui était
incroyable je me souviens doigt dans
l'oeil à l'instant à ripley et le fameux
mode death run qui m'attend fait kiffer
et rager bref je pense que les modes de
counter-strike illustre parfaitement
pourquoi c'est cool qui est des modes et
pourquoi c'est cool que des joueurs
passent du temps à créer ça gratuitement
et bénévolement la plupart du temps des
fois attention ça peut leur apporter de
l'argent d'ailleurs counter strike est à
la base un mode de high flights créé par
un mec 1000 lits je sais pas comment ça
se prononce c'est lui qui a introduit le
thème des terroristes vs les anti
terroriste avec des objectifs qui varier
selon la map dont l'objectif le plus
connu est bien évidemment le amorcer ou
désamorcer la bombe sur ça ouvre moi
j'ai appris que récemment qu'en fait à
la base counter strike était un mode de
hi fly x n'est pas valcke lui l'idée de
counter-strike ces deux mecs
en fait ce gala avec son pote qui gérait
le site qui sont dit [ __ ] mais saturé
si on a ajouté ce thème là avec tel est
l objectif à accomplir tel et tel mode
de jeu je trouve ça incroyable et du
coup parfois quand le mode est vraiment
bon bah ça peut rapporter de l'argent à
ses créateurs comme ça a été le cas pour
ces deux personnes qui ont été
embauchées par valve et ils ont bien
fait [ __ ] quand on voit ce qui est
devenu counter strike mon gars c'est
l'un des jeux vidéo les plus joués au
monde c'est l'un des jeux qui a traversé
le temps le mieux qu'à le mieux vieilli
c'est toujours un classique du fps et
[ __ ] ça vient de deux mecs ont créé un
mode à la base je trouve ça incroyable
alors c'est marrant parce que on se
dirait qu'il ya tout un truc de
propriété intellectuelle on se dirait
mais attend
les mecs concret ce mode là à l'époque
c'était un truc qui appartenait à valve
quand même donc ils ont créé quelque
chose à partir de ce que valve a créé
donc ce qu'ils ont créé à qui ça
appartient exactement mais en fait
beaucoup d'éditeurs et de studios de
développement sont pour les modes y en a
même qui fournissent des kits pour
simplifier la vie aux mecs qui créent
des modes parce que ça fait tout
simplement vivre leur jeu de sa propose
du nouveau contenu gratuit aux joueurs
qui ont déjà acheté le jeu et même
parfois dans les cas où le mode est
vraiment incroyable
les gens vont acheter le jeu juste pour
jouer au mode thermique a créé c'est
vraiment un truc donnant donnant et
c'est aussi plus simple pour les mecs
qui ont envie de créer une sorte de mini
jeux bad de faire un mode dans un jeu
qui existe déjà plutôt que de devoir
coder un jeu entièrement de a à z ça
crée des vrais succès story comme pour
counter-strike et aussi par exemple
comme pour les battle royale les battle
royale ça vient d'un mec qui s'appelle
brendan green qui a créé un mode de arma
2 le mode inspirée du film battle royale
le film japonais mais il a ensuite été
repéré par les développeurs de hnz d'un
pour faire la même chose avec h 15 et
d'ancrer le mode h 15 et d'un battle
royale et ensuite ce gala a quitté day
break les développeurs de hache un zelda
pour s'associer avec un mec en corée du
sud qui avait un studio de jeu et créer
avec lui tu es ubg et tout sa part juste
d'un mode que ce gars a créé pour arma 2
c'est incroyable comme histoire c'est
fou et ensuite
epic games donc qu'ils ont fait en haïti
ont employé ce gars pour créer en ait
battle royale pas du tout ils ont juste
pris l'idée c'est entièrement faux
c'est là où il ya des fois des petits
conflits des petits vols l'idée en fait
le problème de brandon games et qu'il a
créé un truc qui est incroyable mais
quelle générique c'est quand on va pas
verser des royalties au mic a créé les
fps au mec a créé les rpg et brandon
gray il a créé vraiment un mode de jeu à
part entière le battle royale est encore
lui s'en est bien sorti puisqu'il a pu
créer son propre jeu et qui s'est vendu
à des millions d'exemplaires qui s'est
mis bien mais des fois voilà il ya des
mecs qui font un mode qui est vraiment
innovant est cool et malgré qu'ils aient
bossé énormément sur le truc basse et
repris ailleurs etc et ils n'obtiennent
jamais vraiment de compensation
monétaire donc à pas mal de team de mode
parce que c'est des teams des fois les
gens bossent à plusieurs dizaines de
personnes pour certains sur un même mode
parce que c'est beaucoup de temps
minerai de fer un mode bon ça dépend ce
que tu fais vous allez voir mais il ya
des modes qui sont vraiment complexe
affaire le souci c'est qu'un mode fait
part des joueurs ne peut pas être vendus
via par exemple le mode skyrim together
qui permet à des joueurs de se rejoindre
en ligne sur skyrim qui est un jeu à la
base solo mais il est interdit de vendre
le mode parce que le mode dépend d'un
contenu qui n'appartient pas à ceux qui
l'ont créé qui est en l'occurrence qui
appartient à bethesda et donc du coup ce
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils créent un une
campagne de financement donc un pas très
haut
de truc est actuellement au moment où je
fais la vidéo ces gars là ils sont quand
même baquet à hauteur de 23 mille
dollars par mois pour leurs modes skyrim
together donc ils se mettent très très
bien et c'est mérité petit bémol ils
sont accusés les gars confesse karim
together par une autre team d'avoir volé
du code et oued avoir volé des lignes de
codes à loutre team qui du coup est un
vrai manque à gagner et c'est là on
rentre un peu dans le dip modding où il
ya des grosses embrouilles comme ça il
ya des gens qui volent du code à
d'autres gens pour faire des modes qui
rapporte de l'argent du mna liant dunod
et parfois même ya des gens qui font des
modes géniaux que moi à l'époque sur gta
5 j'avais j'avais fait une vidéo où
j'utilisais des modes doigt un mode où
il y avait plein d' avion qui se crashe
est partout et en fait ce mode là
c'était un [ __ ] de virus voilà je lui
ai appris deux semaines après j'ai été
ravi de me dire que des millions de gens
avaient vu cette vidéo et avait
probablement télécharger ce mode qui
contenait un logiciel malveillant visant
à voler les identifiants de plein de
sites quoi voilà vous savez tout c'était
une belle intro boya plein d'infos que
j'ai pas donné que je vulgarise pas mal
de trucs comme d'habitude je vulgarise
un truc déjà vulgariser dans ce que j'ai
vu c'est pour le level de squeeze il est
où il est où il ya donc des modes assez
sérieux à s'écouler ya aussi des modes
qui sont juste nawak c'est vraiment des
gens qui les ont faits pour faire marrer
la communauté pas du tout pour gagner de
l'argent ou quoi que ce soit et
aujourd'hui c'est ces modes là qu'on va
checker ensemble en commençant par mon
préféré dit pinault 23 qui est un gars
qui a une chaîne youtube ou juste il
fait un mode qui en fait augmente les
expressions faciales de 500% du coup les
cinématiques non plus aucune espèce de
sens parce que c'est pas qu'ils allaient
être sensible à ça mais moi comme je
veux beaucoup au jeu ça me fait rire et
non le guennic ce n'est pas fini du tout
c'est faux je les motos jauge de la vie
en prison
il fait plus peur que les horizons des
1000 comme ça mon gars le héros c'est
horrible
ce dégaine h d'armes
on dit de moi quand je suis face à une
situation de crise match mais exactement
cette gueule ça m'angoisse ça me fait
rire à la fois je ne sais pas comment
exprimer ce sentiment ok c'est une scène
d'un mec qui mange des hamburgers donc
du coup au début il est en mode normal
et à la fin il à 1000% êtes vous prêt à
découvrir cette obscénité est-ce que
vous êtes prêts accrochez vous bien à
vos fauteuils annoncé bizarre mais qu il
mange sa propre gueule mais qu'il se
mastique lui-même gros il saute au
mastic à à metz a même plus de sens mais
à part dans resident evil 2 il ya aussi
un grand méchant dans resident evil 2
qui s'appelle monsieur x jeudi resident
evil depuis début mai c'est le
remasterisée qu'est sortie a pas
longtemps restée les deux lui est sorti
à ya vraiment tout un mythe autour de ce
personnage ce qu'il a il a sa place dans
l'histoire il fait vraiment flipper et
il ya des mecs qui sont amusés à créer
un mode où ne se fixe est remplacé par
quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
dovizioso ne laisse pas non il n'y a pas
de raï comment fait-il
il fait peur il écrit pimec à il ya un
an un dossier où les eaux
il est à wall aps voilà donc quelques
extraits ci voulait voir ça
[Musique]
un autre jeu dans lequel il ya
énormément de mode je crois qu'au total
il y en a eu plus de 40000 c'est skyrim
et jensen trop connu au début de karim
ou ya un mec qui s'est exécuté devant
toi c'est au début du jeu et fait
attaquer par un dragon et avec ce mode
le dragon a été remplacé mais je ne
dirais pas par qui par quoi mais vous le
connaissez et croyez moi tient aussi
génial je reviens tu choo s'il vous
plaît oui c'est toby abb pas mais il
fait super peur à ces fous est ce qu'un
bruit et plus intimidant que le choc
c'est un gars qui a vraiment beaucoup a
été fait sur ce qui arrive les gens ils
s'amusaient à changer dragon par
n'importe quoi d'autre mais qui fait
trop vapeur ok drôle j'aime le modding
juste pour ça j'adore ya des mecs qui
ont mis tant d'énergie à faire un mode
où le dragon est remplacé par petit
poney juste pour faire marrer la
communauté j'aime passons maintenant à
mon mode préférées de skyrim
un mode qui reflète ma grande maturité
si jamais on ne savent pas mais je pense
pas dans skyrim est un truc est devenue
un mème qui s'appelle le foot roda c'est
un sort ou ton père sauf un bête de
crier et les ennemis en face de toi
s'envole et ya un mec qui a fait un mode
je vous mets les matches et ça ne me
jugez surtout pas
j'ai paris a tu peux faire des paies
flamme mec dp fulham vraiment dans le
jeu et ça brûle la peau ce bête
merci écoutez moi bien je vais vous je
vais me confesser maintenant ok skyrim
ce monument du jeu vidéo je n'ai jamais
touché et vous savez quoi il vient de se
passer un truc qui illustre parfaitement
ce que j'ai dit au début de la vidéo je
vais acheter ce karim et l'installer
uniquement pour jouer avec ce mode
vraiment alors ensuite un classique du
jeu gta où il ya énormément de mode sur
gta iv mais le chili et de mode mais des
skins des modèles hyundai plains tu
pouvais genre jouets iron man je pouvais
tirer des voitures avec des arts tu
pouvais tirer des requins avec teza il
ya même un mec qui a créé un mode
satanique où tu peut capturer des gens
avec tes pokéball les gens c'est ultra
glauque que tu pouvais aussi jouer bob
les plongent tu pouvais jouer une girafe
tu pouvais jouer spider man mais depuis
elle jeu spider man qui est sorti et
quéven fois mieux donc ça sert plus à
rien mais à l'époque cité où vraiment et
pas son dernier jeu dont je vous parlais
de quelques modes fallout 4 lui aussi
est un jeu édité par bethesda bethesda
qui aime beaucoup les modes et qui
encourage la communauté de ses jeux à
créer des mods d'ailleurs un mec de la
communauté s'échauffer il a créé un mode
ou juste utah une poêle dans ta main
stylet mec je sais ça paraît ridicule
mais tu peux quand même l'améliorer en
scotchant une grosse boîte en métal de
dents et elle fait encore plus mal la
peau à l'air et je sais qu'avec cet
argument tu vas ni décharger le monde ni
acheté fallout 4 du tout mais il ya
aussi un mode dont 24 qui est débile où
il ya juste un pnj c'est un cafard les
cafards normalement tu but et qui
servent à rien dans le jeu là ils en ont
fait un pnj et le pnj par l'etusa
tenteront pas à sa voix et ses drôles
aulas je sais ce que vous dites là poids
ne vous avait pas convaincu vous vouliez
pas à stefan autres 4 mai le cafard met
le holà du cafard vous voulez d'entendre
de mon propre aux oreilles
n'est ce pas écouter les amis c'est à 22
sur les mois je voulais en parler parce
que je trouve que c'est c'est fou c'est
impressionnant et surtout c'est pas mal
d'actualité avec notamment ce qui s'est
passé avec l'apparition du mode battle
royale du coup j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya pas mal des normes nouveautés qui
vont apparaître dans les années à venir
dans le jeu vidéo et qui viendront en
fait d'un mec ou d'une team de mecs qui
ont créé un mode d'un jeu en fait mais
un mode tellement incroyable tellement
cool idée tellement bonne que des
compagnies vont s'en inspirer pour créer
un jeu à part entière avec il ya des
n'emboîtent qui pèse je sais pas combien
en bourse et qui donne les moyens à des
gens de kiffer en fait d'exprimer leur
créativité et je sais pas je trouve ça
c'est beau c'est échanges entre les
joueurs passionnés et les développeurs
des jeux passionné aussi et qui
permettent aux joueurs de prendre en
quelque sorte hommage à leurs jeux
préférés en ajoutant sa petite pierre à
l'édifice et voilà schéma je trouve ça
hyper touchant hyper cool c'était pas
seulement marrant comme vidéo mais au
moins on a appris des choses et puis
j'ai parlé d'un truc que je kiffe donc
voila et qui sait peut-être que ça
donnera envie à des gens d'essayer de
créer des mods
j'espère que ça vous a plu je vous dis à
bientôt une prochaine vidéo et puis
portez vous bien
voilà une belle manière de conclure
cette vidéo et c'était pas un mode
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]